I recorded this conversation with my mom three years before she died. It was for a Mother's Day edition of our radio show, but only a tiny part of it made it onto the air and I listened to the rest yesterday for the first time since then, 16 years ago. I was relieved to hear how well we were getting along, how comfortable we both were because it wasn't always like that with us. Like for instance, we're talking about mothers and Mother's Day and my mom was a therapist and she started telling me about her patients who were mothers and the problems they had with her own grown children.
我在母亲去世前三年录下了这段对话。那是为我们电台节目的母亲节特辑准备的，但只有一小部分在节目中播出。昨天，我十六年来第一次听了剩下的录音。我很欣慰地听到我们当时相处得那么融洽，我们俩都感到很自在，因为我们的关系并非总是如此。例如，我们谈到了母亲和母亲节，我母亲是一名治疗师，她开始向我讲述她的病人，那些身为母亲的人，以及她们与成年子女之间的问题。
They thought they'd be really close. They thought they'd be appreciated. They thought they'd be respected and turned to for advice. That's a big one. That's probably one of the great disappointments is that children don't come to you for advice.
她们以为自己会和孩子很亲近。她们以为会得到感激。她们以为会受到尊重，并被孩子征求建议。这一点很重要。这可能是最大的失望之一，那就是孩子们不会来征求你的建议。
I was glad to hear that we didn't pretend this didn't apply to us. We went for it.
我很高兴听到我们没有假装这与我们无关。我们直面了这个问题。
I think only now would I be able to turn to you for advice.
我想只有现在，我才能够向你征求建议。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
I felt like for so many years, you and dad disapproved so strongly in everything I was doing. It would have been hard.
我感觉很多年来，你和爸爸对我所做的一切都强烈反对。那本会很困难。
What I'm not saying, but she and I both know, is that there were years, like most of my 20s, where she and I barely talked. I didn't want to be in touch with her and my dad. I felt no connection to them for reasons I don't want to go into right now and I am not proud of. I held myself apart.
我没说出口，但她和我都知道的是，有那么几年，比如我20多岁的大部分时间，我和她几乎不说话。我不想和她还有我爸爸联系。出于一些我现在不想细说且并不引以为豪的原因，我感到与他们毫无联系。我把自己孤立了起来。
So if you were to come to me for advice, what kind of advice would you come to me for?
所以，如果你要来向我征求建议，你会问我什么样的建议？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Suppose you were having a problem with your girlfriend.
假设你在和女朋友相处时遇到了问题。
Well, I mean, I think with a girlfriend, I think I would be defensive that you just think, eh, just another relationship I'm messing up, you know?
嗯，我的意思是，我想如果是女朋友，我会产生防御心理，因为你会觉得，哼，又是一段被我搞砸的关系，你知道吗？
So you have a need for me to see you as OK.
所以你需要我把你视为一个“正常”的人。
Yes, but I would argue that you also have a need for me to show you that things are OK.
是的，但我也会说，你也需要我向你证明一切都好。
Mm-hm. That's true.
嗯，那是真的。
Look at us listening to each other, better than I remembered. But there were awkward moments, too, on this recording. I winced hearing myself explain to my mom that we had done three Father's Day shows, but not one Mother's Day show, because I told her people's relationships with their moms are just so much more complicated than their relationships with their dads, as if that was some like universal truth and not just like me and her. And then there's this one question that really makes my mom pause, I mean like literally pause, for 15 seconds. The question is along the lines of have you ever met somebody who actually gets along with her mom? And I'm sure it didn't occur to me that the premise of that question might hurt her feelings, but of course, now I hear all that, like in that pause. OK. Here it is.
看看我们是如何倾听彼此的，比我记忆中要好。但在录音中也有尴尬的时刻。当我向母亲解释我们做了三期父亲节节目，却没做过一期母亲节节目时，我感到局促不安，因为我告诉她，人们与母亲的关系比与父亲的关系复杂得多，仿佛这是某种普遍真理，而不是仅仅发生在我们之间。然后有一个问题真的让我母亲停顿了，我的意思是字面意义上的停顿，足足有15秒。那个问题大致是：你有没有见过真正能和自己母亲相处融洽的人？我敢肯定，当时我没意识到那个问题的前提可能会伤害她的感情，但现在，我当然能听出那一切，就包含在那阵停顿中。好了，就是这个。
Mom, can I ask you to just think for a second about your various clients. How common is it that people have relationships with their mothers where things are going OK? And how common is it troubled?
妈，我能请你花点时间想想你的不同客户吗？人们与母亲的关系还算过得去的有多常见？而出现问题的又有多常见？
I would say the majority of people that I see in therapy are ambivalent about their relationships with both parents.
我会说，我在治疗中见过的绝大多数人对他们与父母双方的关系都抱有矛盾心理。
Yeah.
是啊。
Not one more than the other.
对哪一方都没有更多偏好。
Right.
对。
The question made her feel bad, but I didn't understand that back then. And I spent the last day just feeling this regret and affection for her, which, I guess, is what I was hoping for when I listened yesterday that I would learn something, I would see something I hadn't seen before, that I would have some thought I didn't have back then. Today on our radio show, we have the story of somebody who yearned for that. She went back to a moment from the past, something with her mom from 20 years before hoping to see something new. Though as you'll hear, it's a totally different kind of moment she's returning to, this big difficult event that happened to them and changed their lives forever-- very different from me and my mom. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
那个问题让她感觉很不好，但我当时并不明白。过去这一整天，我都在为她感到后悔和心疼，我想，这就是我昨天听录音时所期待的——我希望能学到些什么，能看到一些我之前没看到的东西，或者能产生一些我当时没有的想法。今天在我们的电台节目中，我们将讲述一个渴望得到那种东西的人的故事。她回到了过去的一个时刻，那是20年前她和母亲之间发生的事，希望能看到一些新的东西。尽管正如你将听到的那样，她所回溯的是一种完全不同的时刻，那是一件发生在她们身上并永远改变了她们生活的重大且艰难的事件——这和我与我母亲的情况大不相同。这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
The story that we're playing you today just won this huge radio award. It's one of the best things produced for radio this year anywhere in the world and we are proud to be the first ones to give it a national broadcast. It was created by the Public Radio website transom.org by Samantha Broun and Jay Allison. It is Samantha's story. A warning before we start that. Part of the story has descriptions of violence, sexual violence. Consider this a trigger warning. It's not right for small children. OK. Here's that story. Here's Samantha Broun.
我们今天播放的这个故事刚刚赢得了巨大的广播奖项。这是今年世界各地制作的最优秀的广播节目之一，我们很自豪能成为第一个全国性播出的平台。它由公共广播网站transom.org的萨曼莎·布朗和杰伊·艾利森制作。这是萨曼莎的故事。在开始之前请注意，故事的一部分包含了暴力和性暴力的描述。请将其视为预警。它不适合小孩子收听。好的，这就是那个故事。有请萨曼莎·布朗。
There's no way to ease into this story, so I'll just start. In 1994, my mother was the victim of a violent crime. She was 55 years old and living alone in Nyack, New York. On the evening of September 21st, a stranger came into her backyard. The stranger attacked her from behind. Five hours later, he left her lying on her bed, hands and feet bound with tape, alive. She survived.
没有办法轻松地切入这个故事，所以我直接开始吧。1994年，我母亲是一起暴力犯罪的受害者。她当时55岁，独自住在纽约州的奈亚克。9月21日傍晚，一个陌生人进入了她的后院。那个陌生人从背后袭击了她。五个小时后，他把她留在床上，手脚用胶带捆住，她还活着。她幸存了下来。
Whatever horrible thing you imagined happened to her in those five hours, likely did. I still find it hard to believe to accept what she went through. I know that a lot of people have been the victims of crimes. I've had my car stolen, my apartment broken into. I felt violated after those events, but what happened to my mom was unimaginable, undigestable. What happened to her changed our view of the world. When Reginald McFadden was arrested and charged with the crimes against my mom, my feeling shifted from terror to outrage. I wanted someone to take responsibility for what went wrong, which is how I ended up testifying in front of a Senate Judiciary hearing in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania.
无论你想象在那五个小时里她经历了什么可怕的事情，很可能都发生了。我仍然觉得难以相信和接受她所经历的一切。我知道很多人都是犯罪的受害者。我的车被偷过，公寓被闯入过。在那些事件之后我感到被侵犯，但我母亲所经历的不仅难以想象，更难以消化。发生在她身上的事改变了我们对世界的看法。当雷金纳德·麦克法登因针对我母亲的罪行被捕并被起诉时，我的感觉从恐惧转为愤怒。我想要有人对出错的事情负责，这就是我最终在哈里斯堡的参议院司法听证会上作证的原因。
I would like to thank Governor Ridge, Attorney General Preate, Chairman Greenleaf--
我要感谢里奇州长、普雷特司法部长、格林里夫主席——
That's me in February 1995 in front of a panel of Pennsylvania senators and a roomful of reporters. And I'm pissed.
那是1995年2月，我面对宾夕法尼亚州参议员小组和满屋子的记者。我很愤怒。
I am here today because last July, Reginald McFadden, a convicted murderer, was released from a Pennsylvania prison.
我今天之所以来到这里，是因为去年七月，雷金纳德·麦克法登，一名被判过谋杀罪的罪犯，从宾夕法尼亚州的监狱中被释放了。
It turned out that the guy who randomly attacked my mom was a convicted murderer and his life sentence without parole had been commuted. After 24 years, he walked out of prison in Pennsylvania and, within days, moved to Nyack, New York, less than a mile from where my mother lived.
事实证明，那个随机袭击我母亲的家伙是一名被判谋杀罪的罪犯，他原本的终身监禁不得假释的判决被减刑了。24年后，他走出了宾夕法尼亚州的监狱，几天之内就搬到了纽约州的奈亚克，距离我母亲居住的地方不到一英里。
On September 21st, while my mother was taking out her garbage, Reginald McFadden--
9月21日，当我的母亲正在倒垃圾时，雷金纳德·麦克法登——
Just take your time.
慢慢来，别急。
Reginald McFadden brutally attacked, then beat, robbed, repeatedly raped, and kidnapped my mother during a five hour ordeal.
雷金纳德·麦克法登残酷地袭击了我的母亲，随后在五个小时的折磨中，殴打、抢劫、反复强奸并绑架了她。
I couldn't understand how Reginald McFadden had been let out of prison and I wanted to be sure whatever crack he slipped through was sealed shut. And it seemed as if that's exactly what happened. The Pennsylvania State Constitution was changed, commutation for lifers became nearly impossible to get. My testimony helped make that happen. My mom's case was a big deal. McFadden was a big deal. It was one of those crimes that makes people angry and scared, that becomes a symbol for a lot of things. And because it happened during an election, it even had an impact on who became the governor of Pennsylvania.
我无法理解雷金纳德·麦克法登是如何被放出监狱的，我想要确保他钻过的每一个漏洞都被彻底封死。而看起来事实确实如此。宾夕法尼亚州宪法被修改了，终身监禁者获得减刑变得几乎不可能。我的证词促成了这一切。我母亲的案件影响巨大。麦克法登的影响力很大。它是那种让人们感到愤怒和恐惧，并成为许多事物象征的罪行之一。而且因为它发生在选举期间，它甚至对谁成为了宾夕法尼亚州州长产生了影响。
A few years ago, nearly 20 years after all this happened, my mother moved from her home in New York to one near me on Cape Cod. I thought it would be an easy adjustment for her, less congestion, more ocean, but it wasn't. Every little sound she was convinced was a stranger in her house. She imagined walks in the woods would have some violent end. She lost sleep. She was scared to death. It was the aftershock from her assault, of course, from McFadden.
几年前，也就是这一切发生近20年后，我母亲从纽约的家中搬到了我居住的科德角附近。我以为这对她来说会是一个轻松的调整，交通没那么拥挤，大海更多，但事实并非如此。她确信每一个细小的声音都是家里的陌生人。她想象在树林里散步会有暴力结局。她失眠。她怕得要死。当然，这是她遭受袭击后的创伤后遗症，来自麦克法登的伤害。
Seeing my mother struggle rattled me. I was surprised at the intensity of it after all these years. I couldn't stand to see her suffering still. That's when I decided I needed to do something. I started digging around, reaching out to people related to the case. I wasn't sure what I was doing exactly or why. I just wanted to get us un-stuck, maybe move the story forward, rethink it, something.
看到母亲挣扎让我感到心烦意乱。在这么多年后，她那种状态的强烈程度令我惊讶。我无法忍受看到她依然在受苦。那时我决定我必须做点什么。我开始挖掘，联系与案件相关的人。我不确定自己到底在做什么，也不知道为什么。我只是想让我们从困境中走出来，也许让故事向前推进，重新思考它，或者做点什么。
I've already told you this isn't an easy story to tell. It won't be an easy one to listen to. I suppose I could start with how the system failed or with McFadden's family in Philadelphia. I could start with the thousands of prisoners whose lives were affected by McFadden, or I could tell you about the political careers, both launched and destroyed. But instead, I think I'll save those parts and start where I usually start, which is with my mother.
我已经告诉过你，这不是一个容易讲述的故事。听起来也不会轻松。我想我可以从体制是如何失败的，或者从麦克法登在费城的家人开始。我可以从成千上万名受麦克法登影响的囚犯开始，或者我可以告诉你那些被开启或被摧毁的政治生涯。但相反，我想我会把那些部分留到后面，从我通常开始的地方说起，那就是我的母亲。
And how are you feeling about today?
你对今天感觉如何？
Well, I'm curious what you're going to ask me about.
嗯，我很好奇你会问我些什么。
Well, I thought today we would talk about September 21st. I have to say, I'm feeling nervous about talking about it, because I don't know that you and I have ever sat across from each other and had this conversation.
好吧，我想今天我们谈谈9月21日那天。我必须说，我对谈论这件事感到紧张，因为我不确定你我是否曾经坐下来面对面进行过这样的对话。
I guess, for me, it's easier when I'm talking to strangers or when I'm just talking about how I survived, but when I tell a loved one, it's much deeper, it just goes deeper into what really happened to my spirit, my soul.
我想，对我来说，和陌生人交谈，或者仅仅谈论我是如何幸存下来的会更容易。但当我告诉亲人时，它会更深入，深入到真正发生在我精神、灵魂深处的东西。
Are you OK to do this?
你确定能做到吗？
I'd like to try. I'd like to try.
我想试一试。我想试一试。
I'd like to try, too, but I worry about it being hard for you. Like I guess I worry that it will bring it to the surface in a way that maybe it hasn't been or it doesn't have to be or that might be hard for you.
我也想试一试，但我担心这对你会很艰难。比如，我担心这会以一种之前没有过的方式，或者本来不需要的方式，将记忆带回表面，这可能会让你感到痛苦。
No, I think we need to try this because we've decided to do it and we're not quitters, are we? Let's try it.
不，我认为我们需要尝试一下，因为我们已经决定要做了，而且我们不是那种会放弃的人，不是吗？我们试试吧。
By the way, my mom is Jeremy Brown. She's in her mid 70s now, but you'd never know it. She looks 15 years younger, she's bright eyed and elegant and full of life. In the fall of 1994, she was living in a little house she had bought after she and my father divorced. I lived there with her for a year or so, working and saving money for graduate school. I moved out at the beginning of September. It was the first time in my mother's adult life that she was living alone.
顺便说一句，我母亲叫杰里米·布朗。她现在七十多岁了，但你绝对看不出来。她看起来年轻了15岁，双眼明亮，优雅且充满活力。1994年秋天，她住在我父母离婚后买的一所小房子里。我和她住在一起大概一年左右，工作并为研究生学费攒钱。我在九月初搬了出去。那是我母亲成年后第一次独自生活。
I was never afraid of anybody. I felt very safe.
我从未怕过任何人。我感觉非常安全。
Do you remember the day of September 21st? Do you remember was it sunny? Did you go to work? Do you remember anything about the day?
你还记得9月21日那天吗？你记得是晴天吗？你去上班了吗？关于那天你还记得什么吗？
My memory is that it was a very ordinary day of going to work
我的记忆是，那是非常平常的一天，我正常去上班。
When this happened my mom was working as a drug and alcohol counselor, helping people kick addictions. When she got home that night--
这件事发生时，我母亲正在做戒毒和戒酒咨询师，帮助人们戒除上瘾。那天晚上她回家后——
It was time I thought to get the recyclables outside and the garbage down to the curb.
那是我想该把可回收垃圾拿到外面，把垃圾送到路边的时候了。
She went out the kitchen, into the breezeway--
她走出厨房，进入门廊——
Through the door and the moon was out and it was lovely out.
穿过门，月亮出来了，外面非常可爱。
She bent over to pick up the box of recyclables and was struck with a fist, a pipe--
她弯下腰去捡那个可回收垃圾箱，然后被拳头，或者水管打了——
It was like if somebody threw a bowling ball at your back. That's how hard it hit me.
就像有人把保龄球朝你的后背扔过来一样。打得真重。
Her arms were pinned behind her.
她的双臂被反绑在背后。
This person put his face right in my neck, next to my ear.
这个人把脸贴在我的脖子上，挨着我的耳朵。
My mother screamed.
我母亲尖叫起来。
He kept yelling, shut up, in my ear, shut up.
他一直在我耳边吼叫，闭嘴，闭嘴。
She struggled. She even bit down on the gloved hand he put over her mouth.
她挣扎着。她甚至咬住了他捂在她嘴上的戴着手套的手。
Did you see him?
你看到他了吗？
No. He was behind me. And after I bit him was when, I believe, he began to hit me in my head and only in my head until I passed out.
没有。他在我身后。在我咬了他之后，我相信，他就开始击打我的头部，只击打我的头部，直到我昏了过去。
My mom grew up about 20 minutes from where she was living in 1994. She is the youngest of five children. Her father was an apple and peach farmer. The story goes that she was supposed to be a boy, which is how she ended up with the name Jeremy. When she was old enough to leave home, she tried college, but dropped out and moved into New York City to make a go of it as a singer. She was in the course of My Fair Lady on Broadway when she met my dad.
我母亲是在离她1994年居住地大约20分钟路程的地方长大的。她是五个孩子中最小的。她父亲是个种苹果和桃子的农夫。传闻说她本该是个男孩，这就是她最后叫杰里米这个名字的原因。当她长到足以离家时，她尝试过大学，但退学搬到了纽约市，想去尝试做一名歌手。她在百老汇出演《窈窕淑女》时遇见了我父亲。
My mom stopped auditioning in the city once she had my brother and me, but she never gave up singing or the theater. It wasn't until her early 50s that she became certified as a drug and alcoholism counselor. She was really good at it. McFadden pulled my mother up and pushed her toward the house. One of her eye sockets was broken, her nose fractured, her teeth knocked loose. Her eyes were swelling shut. McFadden demanded she not look at him. When they got in the house, he draped a towel over my mother's head.
有了我和哥哥后，我母亲就停止在城里参加试镜了，但她从未放弃唱歌或戏剧。直到五十出头，她才获得了戒毒和戒酒咨询师的认证。她在那方面真的很在行。麦克法登把她拉起来，推向房子。她的一个眼窝被打碎，鼻子骨折，牙齿松动。她的眼睛肿得睁不开。麦克法登要求她不准看他。当他们进入房子时，他用毛巾盖住了我母亲的头。
And he started to take my pants off. And I remember so clearly thinking what in the world is he doing. By then, I was a typical rape victim. You go to a place where you have no idea what's going on. None of the words that apply to what's going on come into your head. You're in a space that just does not understand anything so that you can look down at a strange man pulling your pants off and think, why is he doing this? What is this? I don't remember specifically much after that, except that he did rape me on that bed, my bed.
然后他开始脱掉我的裤子。我记得很清楚当时心想，他到底在干什么。那时，我是一个典型的强奸受害者。你会进入一个完全不知道发生了什么的空间。所有适用于当前情况的词汇都不会出现在你的脑海里。你处于一个对一切都毫无理解的空间，所以你可以低头看着一个陌生男人脱掉你的裤子，想，他为什么这样做？这是什么？在那之后我不记得太多具体的了，只记得他在那张床上强奸了我，在那张我的床上。
McFadden started to ask my mom all sorts of questions. She decided not to lie about anything. Her sense was if she was honest, she might connect to something in him.
麦克法登开始问我母亲各种各样的问题。她决定不对任何事情撒谎。她的感觉是如果她诚实，或许能和他建立某种联系。
Something beneath the violence innately, I just knew that I should talk very straight and calmly to this guy and not let him get me hysterical, because I just sort of had a feeling that if I got hysterical, I'd die.
在那层暴力之下的某个地方，我本能地知道我应该非常直接而冷静地与这个家伙谈话，不能让自己歇斯底里，因为我有一种感觉，如果我歇斯底里，我就死定了。
What my mother had no way of knowing then was that McFadden did plan to kill her. In fact, he had murdered Robert Silk on Long Island just two weeks before. The week after he attacked my mom, he sexually assaulted and killed 78-year-old Margaret Kierer, also on Long Island, and Dana DeMarco in Rockland County the week after that. She was 39 years old. The police eventually referred to McFadden as a serial killer. My mother, it turned out, was his only surviving victim.
当时我母亲不可能知道的是，麦克法登计划杀了她。事实上，就在两周前，他刚在长岛杀害了罗伯特·丝克。在袭击我母亲的一周后，他又在长岛性侵并杀害了78岁的玛格丽特·基勒，一周后又在罗克兰县杀害了达娜·德马科。她当时39岁。警方最终将麦克法登称为连环杀手。事实证明，我母亲是他唯一的幸存受害者。
Stories like these get shortened over time to sentences like the one I started with, my mother is the victim of a violent crime, and usually, you leave it at that. I know it's hard to hear the details, but you won't understand why this crime got so much attention and why it's so hard for my mom to get it out of her head if you don't hear what actually happened. So let me try to tell you in a condensed version, for all our sakes, the rest of what happened to my mother that night.
像这样的故事随着时间的推移会被压缩成我开头那样的句子：我母亲是一起暴力犯罪的受害者，通常你也就说到这儿了。我知道听这些细节很难受，但如果你不听到底发生了什么，你就不会理解为什么这起罪行会受到如此多的关注，以及为什么我母亲会那么难以将它从脑海中驱逐出去。所以，为了我们所有人，让我试着把那天晚上发生在我母亲身上的其他事情简要讲出来。
McFadden put my mother in a sleeping bag and took her in her own car to various ATMs to steal her money. He beat her when she tried to escape. There was one point during the night, and this is key, that my mother finally saw him. They were standing in front of a bureau that had a mirror hanging over it. They were looking through her jewelry.
麦克法登把母亲放进一个睡袋里，用她自己的车把她带到各处的ATM机去偷她的钱。当她试图逃跑时，他殴打她。那一夜有一个时刻，这很关键，我母亲终于看到了他。他们站在一个挂着镜子的五斗橱前。他们在翻看她的珠宝。
And I just tipped my head up enough so that my eyes came out from under the towel, and in the mirror I saw him behind me. And he was a black man and he needed a shave.
我刚好把头抬起一点点，让眼睛从毛巾下面露出来，在镜子里我看到了他站在我身后。他是个黑人，需要刮胡子。
What did you think when you saw him?
当你看到他时，你心想什么？
I remember thinking he is cleaner and neater than you would think a criminal doing all these horrible things would be. To me, he was not the stereotypical criminal.
我记得当时心想，他比你想象中那个做尽这些可怕事情的罪犯要干净整洁。对我来说，他不是那种刻板印象里的罪犯。
At the end of the night, he took my mother to a place we now know was off the Garden State Parkway. It's the same spot he took Dana DeMarco two weeks later and where they later found a DeMarco's body. He raped my mother again and then--
那一夜结束时，他把我母亲带到了一个我们现在知道是在花园州公路外的地方。那是他两周后带走达娜·德马科的同一个地点，后来他们也是在那里发现了德马科的尸体。他又强奸了我母亲，然后——
He put both his hands on my neck and started to strangle me. But here's the miracle of all times. I put my hands on top of his and I said in a little voice, what are you doing? You're hurting me. And he let go.
他双手掐住我的脖子，开始勒死我。但这里出现了历史上最大的奇迹。我把双手放在他的手上，用一种微小的声音说，你在干什么？你在伤害我。他就松开了。
What do you think happened? What do you think happened in that moment?
你觉得发生了什么？你觉得那一刻发生了什么？
I hate to use the words like bond or love or anything like that, but by then, he felt bonded somehow or other enough to me to respect me. I think he lost the drive. If you're going to kill a lamb, you're going to have to do it very quickly, right? Because if you start to look at the lamb or listen to the lamb or play with the lamb, you're not going to hurt it. And I think that's what happened.
我不喜欢用像纽带或爱这样的词，但到那时，他觉得以某种方式与我产生了联系，或者至少足以尊重我。我想他失去了杀人的动力。如果你要杀死一只羔羊，你得很快地去做，对吧？因为如果你开始注视这只羔羊，或者倾听这只羔羊，或者和这只羔羊玩耍，你就不会伤害它了。我想这就是发生的事情。
McFadden brought my mother back to her house, bound her hands and feet with tape, and eventually he walked out. It was close to 3:00 in the morning when my mother reached for a phone. She called my brother who lived nearby.
麦克法登把我母亲带回她的房子，用胶带捆住她的手脚，然后离开了。那天凌晨快3点时，我母亲伸手去拿电话。她给住在附近的哥哥打了电话。
And I just flew down that stairs. I don't even remember my feet hitting the stairs into his arms. And he was screaming and he was spinning around for some reason. He sort of put his arms up over his head and he was just running around and around I'm holding him and grabbing him and trying to stop him. And just kept saying, it's OK. It's OK. Get me to the hospital.
我直接从楼梯上飞奔下来。我甚至不记得双脚是如何落到楼梯上的，直接冲进他的怀里。他在尖叫，不知为什么还在转圈。他把双臂举过头顶，只是在那儿不停地转圈，我抱着他，抓着他，试图让他停下来。我只是不停地说，没关系。没关系。带我去医院。
When I got the call that this happened, I packed up my belongings at graduate school and I headed home. When I arrived at the hospital the next day and saw her barely recognizable face, my mother tells me I screamed. My heart had never been broken like this before. I had never been exposed to such violence, never felt the rage that it inspired in me, never imagined I would want revenge like I wanted revenge on Reginald McFadden.
接到电话得知发生了这件事后，我收拾好东西离开研究生院，赶回了家。第二天我到达医院看到她几乎认不出来的脸时，我母亲告诉我我尖叫了。我的心从未像这样破碎过。我从未接触过这样的暴力，从未感受到它激发的愤怒，从未想象过我会像那样想对雷金纳德·麦克法登复仇。
It's difficult to look beyond the devastating details of what happened to my mother that night, but when I do, I see that in the big picture, other things matter, too. The fact is crimes like these are rare, but it's crimes like these-- a black man, a repeat offender, attacking a white middle class woman-- that inspires fear and outrage in communities across the country, and crimes like these that change things, which is exactly what happened next.
很难超越那天晚上发生在我母亲身上的毁灭性细节去看问题，但当我那样做时，我发现从大局来看，其他事情也很重要。事实是，这样的罪行很少见，但正是这样的罪行——一个黑人，一个累犯，攻击一名中产阶级白人女性——激发了全国社区的恐惧和愤怒，也正是这样的罪行改变了某些现状，而这正是接下来发生的事情。
But in the moments before this became swept up in the media, before it became a manhunt, before a jury was selected and a verdict issued, before it ruined some careers and made others, before it was used to change laws, in the moments before all that and in every single moment since, there is simply the unbelievable truth that this happened to my mother.
但在这一切被媒体炒作之前，在它变成一场搜捕之前，在陪审团选出并发布裁决之前，在它毁掉了一些职业并成就了其他人之前，在它被用于修改法律之前，在这一切发生之前的每一个时刻，以及从那以后的每一个时刻，都存在着一个难以置信的事实，那就是这发生在了我母亲身上。
Reginald McFadden was found guilty of raping, robbing, and beating a 55-year-old woman. McFadden--
雷金纳德·麦克法登因强奸、抢劫和殴打一名55岁女性被判有罪。麦克法登——
It did not take the jury long to return a verdict yesterday, 15 minutes.
陪审团昨天没花多久就给出了裁决，15分钟。
Today's verdict means an end to a long and painful ordeal for the victim in this case.
今天的裁决意味着本案受害者漫长而痛苦的磨难结束了。
Most rape victims prefer to remain anonymous, not this 55-year-old social worker.
大多数强奸受害者宁愿保持匿名，而不是这位55岁的社会工作者。
My name is Jeremy, Jeremy Brown. How wonderful it feels to tell you who I am.
我叫杰里米，杰里米·布朗。告诉你我是谁，这种感觉真是太棒了。
Once the trial was over, my mother went public. She gave speeches, made appearances on TV, she was named the Woman of the Year by CBS.
审判结束后，我母亲公开了身份。她发表演讲，在电视上露面，她被CBS评为年度女性。
Has Jeremy Brown earned the place of honor in the history of rape convictions?
杰里米·布朗是否赢得了强奸定罪史上的荣誉地位？
She certainly has and she is certainly, I know an inspiration to many of the women who have not had the ability to go forward.
她当然赢得了，而且我知道，对于许多没有能力站出来的女性来说，她绝对是一种鼓舞。
Beyond the amazing fact that she had survived the attack, there was another reason my mother wanted to speak out. It's that she had survived the trial, too. In one of the most surreal twists of this whole ordeal, Reginald McFadden defended himself in court, which meant he cross-examined my mother. Trial transcripts show exchanges like this. McFadden asked, but at some time in that night, your attacker got out the car and walked around and closed the door and hollered at you? My mother replied, I think he did, he-- you beat on me from the front seat and I was very scared. I thought you were going to kill me right then.
除了她在那场袭击中幸存下来的惊人事实外，我母亲想站出来的另一个原因。那就是她也在审判中幸存了下来。在这整场磨难最离奇的转折之一中，雷金纳德·麦克法登在法庭上为自己辩护，这意味着他盘问了我母亲。庭审记录显示了这样的交流。麦克法登问，但在那晚的某个时候，你的袭击者下车走动，关上门并对你大喊大叫？我母亲回答，我想他是这么做的，你——你在前座殴打我，我非常害怕。我以为你当时就要杀了我。
Basically, I'm mad as hell and I got to talk about it. Think about being tortured by a stranger for five hours, think about listening to his voice telling you all those disgusting things to do for five hours. And then you have to sit in a courtroom, listen to people call him Mr. McFadden. Think what it would do to you to have him say your name.
基本上，我愤怒透顶，我必须谈谈它。试着想象被一个陌生人折磨了五个小时，试着想象听着他的声音，在五个小时里强迫你做那些恶心的事情。然后你不得不坐在法庭里，听人们叫他麦克法登先生。试着想象一下让他叫你的名字对你意味着什么。
My mother shared her story because she felt better when she did, or at least less alone. And because she hoped that by speaking out, it might change things for herself, for others. The day after McFadden sentencing, I returned to graduate school. Eventually, my mother started working again as an addiction counselor. She even moved back into her house. It wasn't easy, but it was important, she said, that he not take the house away from her.
我母亲分享她的故事是因为她这样做时感觉好受些，或者至少不那么孤独。而且因为她希望通过站出来，能为自己和他人改变现状。麦克法登被判刑后的第二天，我回到了研究生院。最终，我母亲又开始从事戒毒咨询工作。她甚至搬回了她的房子。那并不容易，但她说，他不能把这房子从她手里夺走，这一点很重要。
When I set out to interview people, I started with my mom, and then I drew up a list of names-- cops, politicians, journalists, academics, other victims, and my brother.
当我着手采访人们时，我先从我母亲开始，然后列出了一份名单——警察、政治家、记者、学者、其他受害者，还有我哥哥。
Are you nervous?
你紧张吗？
Not really, no.
不怎么紧张，不。
Are you uncomfortable?
你不舒服吗？
I'm a little impatient, so, yes. OK.
我有点没耐心，所以，是的。好吧。
OK. Anyway, I wanted to say-- so you're chewing your gum.
好吧。总之，我想说——所以你在嚼口香糖。
I know, but you're talking.
我知道，但你在说话。
But I can hear it.
但我能听见。
OK.
好吧。
Tim is older than me, but only by 15 months. It's an age difference that has stopped mattering now that we're both approaching 50. You probably remember that Tim was the first person to see my mom the night she was attacked. In 20 years, we've never discussed any of it.
提姆比我大，但只大15个月。随着我们都接近50岁，这种年龄差距已经不再重要了。你可能记得提姆是我母亲遇袭那天第一个见到她的人。20年来，我们从来没有讨论过任何相关细节。
Do you have any questions about it that you've never had answers?
关于这件事，你有什么从未得到过答案的问题吗？
No. I don't. You know, part of me is like, I guess, maybe I'm in denial about it. I don't know. But a lot of people have been through a lot of really bad shit and that includes seeing people killed, car accidents, going to war, physical abuse, you name it. It's all out there, you know, so I don't think about why or why my mother or it's a fucking horrible thing that happened, really bad, but she's alive and, you know, she's completely physically capable person who's living a full and rich life. And it was a long time ago. But as far as I know, I don't carry it around with me as some weight or stone or what have you.
没有。我没有。你知道，我的一部分感觉就像，也许我对它有否认心理。我不知道。但很多人经历过很多真正糟糕的事情，包括目睹人被杀、车祸、参加战争、身体虐待，等等。这些都在发生，你知道，所以我不会去想为什么，或者为什么是我母亲，或者这是一件极其可怕的事情，真的很糟糕，但她还活着，你知道，她是一个完全有行为能力的健康人，过着充实而富足的生活。那都是很久以前的事了。但据我所知，我并没有把它当作某种负担或沉重的石头一直背负着。
I do still carry it with me. Sometimes, it sits so quietly, I think it might be gone. But other times, it courses through my system with such surprise and force, it makes me dizzy. It happens in mundane moments. Like recently, my mom called from a highway rest stop to say hello and that she just bought a hot dog. It suddenly hits me she survived a serial killer. And the reality of what could have happened overwhelms me.
我确实还在背负着它。有时候，它沉静地坐着，我以为它可能消失了。但另一些时候，它以如此惊人和强烈的力量流经我的身体，让我感到头晕目眩。这发生在平凡的时刻。比如最近，我母亲在高速公路休息站打电话来打个招呼，说她刚买了个热狗。我突然意识到她从连环杀手手中幸存了下来。而可能发生的事情的现实压得我喘不过气来。
I explained to Tim that I'm headed out to find the others who were affected by this event. I tell them I have questions I want answered and I think talking to others will help somehow. I tell him I think about forgiveness. I hope that doesn't seem crazy, but that's what we're taught, right? That if we can forgive, we get some sort of relief. But how do you do that? I know my mother is very clear. She'll never forgive McFadden and I could guess about my brother.
我向提姆解释说我正要去寻找其他受此事件影响的人。我告诉他们我有一些想要得到答案的问题，而且我觉得和其他人交谈会以某种方式提供帮助。我告诉他我思考过宽恕。我希望那看起来并不疯狂，但这就是我们被教导的，对吧？如果我们能宽恕，我们就能得到某种解脱。但你该怎么做呢？我知道我母亲的态度很明确。她永远不会宽恕麦克法登，我也能猜到我哥哥的想法。
Do you think you've forgiven him?
你觉得你宽恕他了吗？
No.
没有。
Do you think you need to or want to?
你觉得你需要或者想要宽恕他吗？
Me? Not particularly. Fuck him. I don't give a shit about him. I don't even really like discussing it, to be honest with you, although this has been OK.
我？并不是特别想。去他的。我才不在乎他。说实话，我甚至不太喜欢讨论它，尽管这次还算可以。
Why don't you like discussing it?
你为什么不喜欢讨论它？
I don't really see the point.
我真的没觉得有什么意义。
I wish I have a little bit of that. I mean, I'm doing the opposite thing here. I'm like talking to lots of people. What do you think of that? What do you think about me talking like--
我希望我也能有那么一点这种想法。我的意思是，我正在做相反的事情。我像是在和很多人谈话。你觉得那样怎么样？你觉得我谈论这些——
I'm kind of curious what the point of the whole project is, but go for it, you know. Let's see where it goes. I don't know. Good for you. Better you than me.
我有点好奇整个项目的意义是什么，但去做吧，你知道。让我们看看它会走向何方。我不知道。为你高兴。还好是你而不是我。
I hope he's right. Near the top of my list of people to talk to were the men who had voted on McFadden's commutation from prison in Pennsylvania. Some background first. Pretty much the only way out for lifers in Pennsylvania, besides escape or death, is to have their sentence commuted. Historically, commutation has been common practice there. It serves as a release valve, a way to reward good behavior, and give prisoners sentenced to life hope for a second chance.
我希望他是对的。在我交谈名单的前列，是那些投票决定在宾夕法尼亚州假释麦克法登的人。先介绍点背景。在宾夕法尼亚州，终身监禁者除了越狱或死亡，几乎唯一的出路就是减刑。从历史上看，减刑在那里是常见做法。它作为一种释放阀，一种奖励良好表现的方式，给被判终身监禁的囚犯以第二次机会的希望。
After serving 25 to 30 years of a life sentence, if lifers show remorse and behave themselves in prison, they have a shot at commutation. The crime McFadden was seeking commutation for happened in 1969. He was convicted of the burglary and murder of Sonia Rosenbaum, a 60-year-old woman in Philadelphia. McFadden committed the crime with three other teenagers. He was 16, at the time. His record was already filled with over a dozen arrests. And for this crime, he was sentenced to life without parole.
在服刑25到30年终身监禁后，如果终身囚犯表现出悔意并在狱中表现良好，他们就有机会获得减刑。麦克法登寻求减刑的那起犯罪发生在1969年。他因入室盗窃和谋杀一名60岁的费城女性索尼娅·罗森鲍姆而被定罪。麦克法登和其他三名青少年一起犯下了这起罪行。他当时16岁。他的记录已经充满了十几次逮捕。而对于这起罪行，他被判处终身监禁不得假释。
By 1992, McFadden had been in prison for just over 20 years. He had applied for commutation seven times with no luck. The eighth time was different. He succeeded.
到1992年，麦克法登已经在狱中待了20多年。他申请过七次减刑，都无果而终。第八次有所不同。他成功了。
I was very skeptical to my fellow pardons board members.
我对我的同事假释委员会成员们持非常怀疑的态度。
Republican Ernest Preate was the Attorney General for Pennsylvania in the late '80s, early '90s. He was the only person to vote no on McFadden's commutation.
共和党人欧内斯特·普雷特是80年代末、90年代初宾夕法尼亚州的司法部长。他是唯一一个投票反对麦克法登减刑的人。
I said, I don't like this guy. I don't think he's ready to go. Very, very hesitant to recommend him to the governor.
我说，我不喜欢这个家伙。我不认为他准备好了出来。非常，非常犹豫是否要向州长推荐他。
Preate thought McFadden was too young, just 39, and that he could easily go on to commit other crimes. He told me something else that shed light on the case. Apparently, the Department of Corrections supported McFadden, because McFadden had ratted on fellow prisoners during violent riots that erupted at the Camp Hill prison in the 1980s.
普雷特认为麦克法登太年轻，才39岁，他很容易继续犯下其他罪行。他告诉了我另一件事，这为案件提供了线索。显然，惩教署支持麦克法登，因为麦克法登在20世纪80年代坎普希尔监狱爆发暴力骚乱期间出卖过同狱犯人。
The department was recommending, the Department of Corrections, was recommending him so that this was part of the payback to McFadden was we'll recommend you for a commutation, because you've been helpful to us in dealing with the riot at Camp Hill.
惩教署在推荐他，这也是对麦克法登的一种回报，即我们会推荐你减刑，因为你在处理坎普希尔骚乱方面帮了我们大忙。
Nearly everyone I spoke with mentioned that McFadden's cooperation at Camp Hill helped him get his commutation.
我交谈过的几乎每个人都提到，麦克法登在坎普希尔的合作帮助他获得了减刑。
I have a feeling it's going to be grueling
我有一种感觉，这会非常折磨人。
I get the sense that you're scared.
我感觉到你在害怕。
I'm scared of something. I don't know what it is.
我在害怕些什么。我不知道那是什么。
Well, I'm nervous about this. I mean, I have thought a lot about you over the last 20 years.
好吧，我对这件事很紧张。我的意思是，在过去20年里，我思考过很多关于你的事情。
Five people sit on the Pennsylvania board of pardons. When McFadden applied for commutation in 1992, Democrat Mark Singel was the Lieutenant Governor and the head of the board. Although his vote counted the same as everyone else's, it was Mark Singel, more than anyone, who was blamed for what happened once McFadden got out. He was the former board member I most wanted to talk to. When I thought of other people who must be haunted by this event, I thought Mark Singel.
宾夕法尼亚州假释委员会由五人组成。当麦克法登在1992年申请减刑时，民主党人马克·辛格尔是副州长兼委员会主席。虽然他的投票和其他人一样权重，但马克·辛格尔比任何人都更因麦克法登获释后发生的事情而受到指责。他是我最想交谈的前委员会成员。当我想到还有哪些人一定被这件事所困扰时，我想到了马克·辛格尔。
The Board of Pardons was always skeptical. I mean, the numbers of people that we even consider was minuscule, microscopic.
假释委员会总是持怀疑态度。我的意思是，我们甚至考虑的人数都是微乎其微的。
The board never met Reginald McFadden. Amazingly, that wasn't part of the commutation process in Pennsylvania. But others spoke on his behalf, and McFadden had to submit piles of paperwork, including descriptions of past crimes, names of current sponsors, and accomplishments in prison.
委员会从来没见过雷金纳德·麦克法登。令人惊讶的是，这在宾夕法尼亚州的减刑过程中不是必须的。但其他人代表他发言，麦克法登必须提交成堆的文件，包括过去犯罪的描述、当前担保人的姓名以及在狱中的成就。
What I recall about the McFadden presentation was that everybody was on board. The psychologist and the warden and the corrections people were all saying that this is somebody who had done extraordinarily well.
我关于麦克法登陈述的记忆是，每个人都同意。心理学家、监狱长和惩教人员都说这是一个表现极其出色的人。
The board voted 4 to 1 in favor of McFadden's commutation. Singel voted yes. He believed he was doing the right thing.
委员会以4比1投票赞成麦克法登减刑。辛格尔投了赞成票。他认为自己在做正确的事。
I have to tell you that my own personal background, I grew up in a very Catholic and a specific type of Catholicism, Byzantine Catholic. When we were very young, the whole family would go in and sing the mass every day in old Slavonic and the phrase that we would sing over 100 times during the liturgy was Gospodi pomilui, Lord have mercy, Lord have mercy. And my family believed in that.
我必须告诉你，我自己的个人背景，我在一种非常天主教的、特定类型的天主教——拜占庭天主教中长大。当我们很小的时候，全家人每天都会去唱拜占庭弥撒，用古斯拉夫语，在礼拜仪式中我们会重复唱100多次的短语是“Gospodi pomilui”，即“主啊，怜悯我，主啊，怜悯我”。我家人相信这一点。
That makes you emotional.
那让你情绪化了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
So you felt like here you were in a position to have mercy on people.
所以你感觉你处于一个可以怜悯人的位置。
To do my job as a human being, not just as the Lieutenant Governor.
去做我作为一个人应该做的工作，不仅仅是作为副州长。
When McFadden walked out of prison, he was 41 and had never spent a day of his adult life as a free man. Surprisingly, McFadden didn't go to a halfway house, a bureaucratic oversight. McFadden's transition didn't go well. Within a month, he went through two or three jobs and started stealing from his roommate. Within two months, he started to spiral out of control, killing Robert Silk, Margaret Kierer, and Dana DeMarco, and of course, attacking my mom.
当麦克法登走出监狱时，他41岁，从未以自由人的身份度过成年后的一天。令人惊讶的是，麦克法登没有去中途之家，这是一个行政疏忽。麦克法登的转变并不顺利。一个月内，他换了两三份工作，并开始偷他室友的东西。两个月内，他开始失控，杀害了罗伯特·丝克、玛格丽特·基勒和达娜·德马科，当然，还有袭击我母亲。
During the first week of October, just 92 days after he was released from prison, Reginald McFadden was arrested as the prime suspect of these crimes. News of McFadden's arrest arrived in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania where Democrat, Mark Singel, was ahead in the governor's race against Republican Tom Ridge. In October of 1994, Tom Ridge wasn't well-known, not even in Pennsylvania. He was a Congressman representing a small rural district. Mark Singel, on the other hand, had been the Lieutenant Governor for nearly eight years. The feeling across the state was that Mark Singel was a shoo-in.
10月的第一个星期，在他出狱仅仅92天后，雷金纳德·麦克法登因作为这些罪行的首要嫌疑人被捕。麦克法登被捕的消息传到了宾夕法尼亚州的哈里斯堡，那里民主党人马克·辛格尔正在州长竞选中领先共和党人汤姆·里奇。1994年10月，汤姆·里奇并不出名，甚至在宾夕法尼亚州也是如此。他是一位代表一个小农村选区的国会议员。另一方面，马克·辛格尔已经担任副州长近八年了。全州的感觉是马克·辛格尔稳操胜券。
So they were ready to just simply transfer the mantle and I could feel it all across Pennsylvania. Tom Ridge never got close, never got close.
所以他们准备好直接移交权杖了，我能在宾夕法尼亚州各地感受到这一点。汤姆·里奇从来没接近过，从来没接近过。
And then McFadden happened.
然后麦克法登的事发生了。
And all they had to do was to put an ad up and put McFadden's picture out there, say see? We told you. This is what happens when you're weak on crime.
他们所要做的只是打个广告，把麦克法登的照片放出来，说看到了吗？我们告诉过你们了。这就是你在犯罪问题上软弱时会发生的事。
Mark Singel votes to free a convicted murderer. The man Mark Singel voted to free is arrested for rape and murder. Mark Singel, bad judgement, too liberal on crime. How can we ever trust him again? There's a better choice, Tom Ridge. The judgement and character we trust.
马克·辛格尔投票释放了一名被判谋杀罪的罪犯。马克·辛格尔投票释放的男人因强奸和谋杀被捕。马克·辛格尔，判断力差，对犯罪过于自由派。我们怎么还能相信他？有一个更好的选择，汤姆·里奇。我们所信任的判断力和品格。
And then, everything shifted. The whole tectonic plates of my universe changed and we watched that campaign disintegrate. It went from an eight point lead to us being seven points behind in 48 hours. 15 point swing. I've never, ever seen that in politics.
然后，一切都变了。我宇宙的整个地壳板块都改变了，我们看着那场竞选分崩离析。在48小时内，我们从领先8个百分点变成了落后7个百分点。15个百分点的反转。我从来，从来没在政治中见过这种情况。
Mark Singel's career as a politician was over and Tom Ridge's was about to soar. It took months and a lot of persistence to land an interview with Ridge.
马克·辛格尔的政治生涯结束了，而汤姆·里奇的职业生涯即将飞速上升。我花了几个月时间和巨大的坚持才争取到采访里奇的机会。
My understanding is that from what I've read and from what I remember that Reginald McFadden was a real turning point in the election. Do you see it that way?
我的理解是，根据我读过的和记得的，雷金纳德·麦克法登是选举中的一个真正转折点。你也是这么看的吗？
Well I can't, I mean, I can't doubt that it had an impact, but from my perspective, what it did for me was put an exclamation point on what I've been talking about for over a year.
嗯，我不能怀疑它产生了影响，但从我的角度来看，它为我所做的是给我谈论了一年多的事情加了一个惊叹号。
I met Tom Ridge in a huge suite of offices in downtown Washington DC, where he now runs a security consulting firm. In 2001, George W. Bush asked Ridge to leave his post as Governor of Pennsylvania and to join him at the White House to head up what would become the new Department of Homeland Security. But back in 1995, having beaten Mark Singel in the election, Tom Ridge was being sworn in as the Governor of Pennsylvania. The main thing that won the election was his stance on crime.
我在华盛顿特区市中心的一间巨大的办公室里见到了汤姆·里奇，他现在经营着一家安全咨询公司。2001年，乔治·W·布什请里奇离开宾夕法尼亚州州长的职位，加入白宫，领导后来成为新的国土安全部的机构。但在1995年，在选举中击败马克·辛格尔后，汤姆·里奇就任宾夕法尼亚州州长。赢得选举的主要因素是他在犯罪问题上的立场。
And so once elected, what did you feel your mandate was then on this issue?
那么一旦当选，你当时觉得你在这个问题上的授权是什么？
Well I told cloaks, if you elect me, one of the first things that I'm going to do, I'm going to call a special session on crime and that's exactly what we did.
我告诉过幕僚们，如果你选我，我做的第一件事就是召开一次关于犯罪的特别会议，而这正是我们所做的。
The same special session on crime that I testified in, the same special session that focused on getting tough and, essentially, putting an end to any chance of commutation for lifers. Here's the thing, this was the mid '90s. Crime was one of the top issues on most voters' minds in Pennsylvania and across the country. People wanted to feel safe. For Tom Ridge, who was already running as a tough on crime candidate, Reginald McFadden's spree was, strange to say, perfectly timed. Although sprees like McFadden's are extremely rare, it had the exact class and racial components to draw in the media and incite public hysteria.
就是我作证的那次关于犯罪的特别会议，就是那次专注于强硬，本质上结束了终身囚犯减刑机会的特别会议。关键是，那是90年代中期。犯罪是宾夕法尼亚州乃至全国大多数选民最关心的问题之一。人们想要感到安全。对于已经是“打击犯罪”候选人的汤姆·里奇来说，雷金纳德·麦克法登的暴行，说来奇怪，时机恰到好处。虽然像麦克法登这样的暴行极为罕见，但它具备了吸引媒体并煽动公众歇斯底里的确切阶级和种族成分。
A lot of people who I've spoken to talk about the constitutional changes that went into effect as a result of the special session and that that makes it nearly impossible for people to have their sentence commuted. And I, as a person who testified at that special session and perhaps contributed to those changes being made, I think about that a lot, because I think about the lives that are being impacted. Do you ever think about those changes and wonder if, perhaps, they're too strict or wonder about the impact of those changes and the reduced number of people getting commuted?
很多我交谈过的人都在谈论由于特别会议而生效的宪法变更，以及这使得人们几乎不可能获得减刑。而我，作为一个在那次特别会议上作证并可能促成了这些变更的人，经常思考这个问题，因为我思考着那些被影响的生命。你是否曾经思考过这些变更，并怀疑它们是否可能过于严厉，或者怀疑这些变更的影响以及获得减刑人数的减少？
Candidly, that's a fair question and I haven't given it much thought. But most of my opinions I hold today, I held 20 or 30 years ago, but not all of them. So.
坦白说，这是一个公平的问题，我并没有过多地考虑它。但我今天持有的观点，大多数在20或30年前我就有了，但并非全部。所以。
I've asked everybody this question and I think all the people that I'm meeting with are-- I'm choosing because I believe this incident changed their life personally, and I'm wondering how you think this incident, McFadden, changed your life, personally?
我问过每个人这个问题，我想我选择与这些人会面，是因为我相信这次事件在个人层面上改变了他们的生活，我想知道你是怎么想这件事的——麦克法登是如何在个人层面上改变了你的生活的？
I hope you're not disappointed, but I'm not sure it did. It changed your mother's life, it changed the lives of many families. It's certainly in a positive way I'd like to think changed the lives of hundreds, if not thousands, of other families and victims, but for me personally, the only thing it did was to re-affirm in my own mind that the approach I took towards reforming some of the criminal justice system was the right thing to do.
我希望你不会失望，但我不确定它改变了。它改变了你母亲的生活，改变了许多家庭的生活。我确实希望它在某种程度上以一种积极的方式改变了成百上千甚至更多其他家庭和受害者的生活，但对我个人而言，它唯一做到的事情就是在我心中重申，我所采取的改革刑事司法体系的方法是正确的。
I think my personal connection to all this made some of the people I interviewed nervous and careful. That's understandable and it made me all the more grateful to Mark Singel, the guy who lost the election, for the way he talked to me, like when I asked him difficult questions like this one.
我认为我与这一切的个人联系让一些我采访过的人感到紧张和谨慎。这可以理解，这让我更加感谢马克·辛格尔，那个输掉选举的人，因为他与我交谈的方式，比如当我问他像这样的难题时。
If you had the chance to say something to my mom or to the family members of the other--
如果你有机会对我的母亲或其他——的家人说点什么——
Just that I'm terribly sorry. That I feel to the people who were the immediate victims I hurt them and I didn't mean to. So there you have it.
只是我非常抱歉。我感到对于那些直接受害者，我伤害了她们，我本无意如此。所以，就是这样。
Hearing Mark Singel say this eased something in me. My mother felt the same way when I played it for her.
听到马克·辛格尔这么说，我心里轻松了一些。当我播放给母亲听时，她也有同样的感受。
That's wonderful that he expressed such personal feelings with you, because that's the human being.
他能对你表达出如此个人的感受真是太好了，因为那才是人性所在。
The last time we talked and we went through what happened on September 21st, how is that for you?
上次我们交谈并回顾了9月21日发生的事情，这对你感觉如何？
I think it went pretty well. I do. Is it difficult for me to share it or to revisit it? No. It's a reality for me. I guess some difficulty is carrying it around and--
我认为进行得还不错。确实。分享它或重温它对我来说困难吗？不。这是我的现实。我想背负着它确实有一些困难，并且——
What are the scars you have from this? I don't know if you actually have physical scars, but any kind of scars. What are the scars that you have?
你从这件事中留下了什么伤疤？我不知道你是否有实际的身体伤疤，但任何形式的伤疤。你有什么伤疤？
I can't sing. That's it. It's huge.
我不能唱歌。就是这样。这影响很大。
What does it mean for you not to be able to sing?
不能唱歌对你意味着什么？
Well, I was a bird who could sing. I can sing, right? But I cry, so it stops me and that's very painful because that was who I was. I was a girl who was born with a voice and I could sing and I can't now.
嗯，我曾经是一只会唱歌的鸟。我可以唱歌，对吧？但我会哭，所以这阻碍了我，这非常痛苦，因为那才是我的样子。我是一个天生就有嗓音的女孩，我曾经能唱，但现在不能了。
It's true. My mother was not only a singer on Broadway, but she used to be one of those people who would break into song in public places. I haven't heard that in years. By this time, I'd been working on this project for well over a year. I still had people I wanted to talk to-- prison staff, former inmates, and people close to McFadden, like Charlotte.
是真的。我母亲不仅是百老汇的歌手，她过去还是那种会在公共场合突然唱起歌来的人。我已经多年没听到过了。到这个时候，我已经在这个项目上工作了一年多了。我还有我想交谈的人——监狱工作人员、前囚犯，以及像夏洛特这样与麦克法登亲近的人。
Let me just say I really appreciate that you're sitting here, because I've thought about you for a long time, your family, and it took me 20 years to pick up the phone and figure out where you were. And even once I thought I knew your number, it took me a long time to make the call. And then I felt bad every time I called back because I thought they don't want to talk to me, you know.
让我说，我真的很感激你坐在这里，因为我为你、为你的家庭想了很久，我花了20年才拿起电话并弄清楚你在哪里。甚至当我以为我知道你的号码时，我也花了很长时间才打出那个电话。然后每次回拨时我都感到难过，因为我以为他们不想和我交谈，你知道。
And you know what is true? You still want to led you right, but look where it put you.
你知道什么是真的吗？你仍然想引诱正确的人，但看看它把你带到了哪里。
It was mid-July, hot, and I was sitting in a car with Charlotte McFadden, Reginald's youngest sister. We were in front of her house in Philadelphia, the house McFadden grew up in. Charlotte had no idea I was coming, neither did I, until I decided to the day before. When I got there, she was out on the street working with a neighbor under the hood of her car. I saw her and immediately knew she was a McFadden. She knew who I was, too.
那是7月中旬，天气炎热，我正和雷金纳德最小的妹妹夏洛特·麦克法登坐在车里。我们在费城她家门前，那是麦克法登长大的房子。夏洛特不知道我要来，我也不确定，直到前一天我决定要来。当我到达时，她正在街上和邻居一起修理引擎盖下的车。我看到她，立刻就知道她是麦克法登家的人。她也知道我是谁。
I felt it. That's why I turned my back because I couldn't look at you because I felt it, too.
我感觉到了。这就是为什么我背过身去，因为我无法看你，因为我也感觉到了。
It was an awkward beginning, but we ended up talking for over an hour. I asked her how things have been for her all these years.
开始时很尴尬，但我们最终交谈了一个多小时。我问她这些年来她过得怎么样。
I still, like inside hurts. I'm in here hurting because I have to squeeze it down just to get through. Even like now, like when I go to use my name, certain bells get rung because people say McFadden.
我依然，内心深处在痛。我在这里受着煎熬，因为我必须压抑住它才能活下去。即使现在，就像当我使用我的姓氏时，特定的铃声会响起，因为人们说“麦克法登”。
Charlotte talked about her brother and what his crimes had done to her family. She said he was pretty young when he started getting into trouble, but for her, he was always her protector. Charlotte had questions for me, too.
夏洛特谈到了她的哥哥以及他的罪行对她的家庭所做的一切。她说他开始惹麻烦时还很年轻，但对她来说，他一直都是她的保护者。夏洛特也有问题要问我。
Your mom, like, I would love to give her a hug and let her know that I'm glad she survived it and everything is OK, but I know somewhere in her head, she got to be still going through a turmoil. It's hard, probably, very hard for her and it's understandable.
你的妈妈，就像，我很想给她一个拥抱，让她知道我很高兴她幸存了下来，一切都还好，但我知道在她脑海里的某个地方，她一定还在经历动荡。这可能很艰难，非常艰难，这是可以理解的。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know, it is very understandable. Is she OK now?
你知道，这非常可以理解。她现在还好吗？
She's OK, but it haunts her every day.
她还好，但它每天都在困扰着她。
Mm-hmm. I can imagine.
嗯。我能想象。
Do you think-- I think about forgiveness a lot, because I would really like to forgive your brother. And I think that's part of me doing this, too, is I want to understand him and why he did what he did. And I think if I could forgive him, I'd feel better.
你觉得——我经常思考宽恕，因为我真的想宽恕你的哥哥。我想这也是我做这个的一部分，我想理解他以及他为什么那样做。我觉得如果我能宽恕他，我会感觉好受些。
So you haven't forgiven him yet?
所以你还没宽恕他？
I feel like I walk towards it, but when I talk to my mom and see how she carries it, I feel like I might be disloyal to her if I forgave him.
我觉得我正朝着那个方向走，但当我与母亲交谈并看到她是如何背负着它时，我觉得如果我宽恕他，我会对她不忠。
That's understandable, though.
那也完全可以理解。
Coming up, approaching McFadden. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，接近麦克法登。节目继续后将会在一分钟内播出。
This American Life, Ira Glass. All this hour, we're hearing Samantha Broun's story. We're visiting a crime committed two decades ago by Reginald McFadden and its aftermath. Again, here's Samantha.
这里是《美国生活》，艾拉·格拉斯。在这整整一小时里，我们一直在听萨曼莎·布朗的故事。我们正在回顾二十年前雷金纳德·麦克法登犯下的一起罪行及其余波。再次有请萨曼莎。
Interviewing McFadden himself was something I'd always thought about. And after talking with Charlotte, I felt it was the obvious next step. I wanted to sit across from him. I needed to hear if he was remorseful. If he was remorseful and I could believe him, maybe that would help, maybe. But when I called Attica, the prison in New York where he is now, to ask about interviewing him, I was told that McFadden is in solitary confinement. He'll be there for five years. He had pulled a fake gun on prison guards. He had planned to escape.
采访麦克法登本人一直是我考虑的事情。在与夏洛特交谈后，我觉得这是显而易见的下一步。我想坐在他对面。我需要听听他是否有悔意。如果他有悔意，而我能相信他，也许那会有所帮助，也许。但当我给纽约他现在所在的阿提卡监狱打电话要求采访他时，我被告知麦克法登正在被单独监禁。他要在那里待上五年。他曾用假枪威胁狱警。他曾策划越狱。
On top of that, prison officials and crime victim advocates expressed concern about my wanting to talk to him. They described McFadden as manipulative and unpredictable, and I began to fear he might say things about what happened that night that I wouldn't want to hear. Still, I tried several avenues to get to him through the Department of Corrections, but I was denied permission to record. I do have some courtroom audio of him during the period of his murder convictions, just to give you an idea of who he was then. The music was added by a TV show it was used on.
除此之外，监狱官员和犯罪受害者权益倡导者对我想和他交谈表示担忧。他们形容麦克法登操纵性强且不可预测，我开始担心他可能会说出一些关于那天晚上发生的事情的我不愿听的话。尽管如此，我尝试了几种途径通过惩教署联系他，但我被拒绝了录音许可。我确实有一些他在谋杀定罪期间的庭审音频，只是为了让你了解他当时是什么样子。背景音乐是电视节目后来添加的。
I guess this is an opportunity for me to say I'm remorseful, I'm sorry. Well, I'm not remorseful and I'm not sorry because I'm not guilty. OK. Give me the maximum sentence. Matter of fact, give me 1,000 years because it wouldn't make a difference. Oh, if it was possible for me to sign my own death warrant, I don't fear death because I've seen death 1,000 times over. It don't make a difference to me. Humph.
我想这是一个我表达悔意、道歉的机会。好吧，我没有悔意，也不道歉，因为我没有罪。好吧。给我最高判决。事实上，给我1000年，因为那也不会有任何不同。噢，如果可能的话让我签下我自己的死刑判决，我不怕死，因为我已经见过1000次死亡。这对我来说没什么区别。哼。
Since I couldn't record a conversation with McFadden, I tracked down someone who had spent time with him, Mark Safarik, a former profiler with the FBI, who classified McFadden as a psychopath.
由于我无法录下与麦克法登的对话，我追踪到了一个与他待过一段时间的人，马克·萨法里克，前FBI分析师，他将麦克法登归类为精神变态者。
In my fantasy version of all of this, I was going to end up going to meet him and we'd have a conversation in which he had some remorse and that would help.
在我这一切的幻想版本中，我本打算去见他，我们会进行一次对话，在那次对话中他表现出了一些悔意，那会有所帮助。
And he, honestly, might tell you that he's remorseful and sorry for what he did. I don't believe that that would be true. And he will clearly understand who you are and, in a sense, why you're there and I think he would make an effort to twist that in a way that would be harmful and hurtful. I don't think anything good could come out of it.
而他，老实说，可能会告诉你他有悔意并为自己所做的事感到抱歉。我不相信那是真的。他会清楚地明白你是谁，并且在某种程度上明白你为什么在那儿，而且我认为他会努力将其扭曲成一种有害和伤人的方式。我不认为从中能得到任何好结果。
So how is there resolution? Because I don't feel it.
那么该如何解决呢？因为我没有感觉到解决。
Yeah, I don't know that there is. What's the resolution, you know? He's incarcerated for the rest of his life. Was it a mistake to let him out? Absolutely. He should never have been let out. But I don't know that there's ever any resolution. I think, certainly, the edges of those wounds get softer, but those wounds never go away. They never heal.
是啊，我不知道是否有什么解决。什么是解决，你知道吗？他余生都将在监禁中度过。放他出来是个错误吗？绝对是。他不应该被放出来。但我不知道是否会有什么真正的解决。我想，当然，那些伤口的边缘会变软，但那些伤口永远不会消失。它们永远不会愈合。
Talking to Mark Safarik, I understood, or maybe I should say I finally accepted, that I'd never get what I wanted from McFadden. I'm not going to see him express remorse. What I'm left with is my own remorse for something I feel guilty about and that's what has happened to lifers in Pennsylvania. That may sound weird, but I know my testimony contributed to their current situation.
与马克·萨法里克的交谈让我明白，或者我应该说我终于接受了，我永远不会从麦克法登那里得到我想要的东西。我不会看到他表达悔意。我剩下的是我对某件我感到内疚的事情的悔意，那就是发生在宾夕法尼亚州终身囚犯身上的事情。这听起来可能很奇怪，但我知道我的证词促成了他们目前的处境。
Each of you is in a position to do something. You will have the opportunity to vote on legislative changes that would reduce the chances of something like this from ever happening again. You owe it to Sonia Rosenbaum, to Margaret Kierer, to Robert Silk, and to my mother.
你们每一个人都有能力做点什么。你们将有机会对立法变更进行投票，这将减少类似事情再次发生的可能性。你们亏欠索尼娅·罗森鲍姆、玛格丽特·基勒、罗伯特·丝克以及我的母亲。
My words may have made only a small contribution to the changes that were to come, but they were still part of it. As a result of that Special Session on Crime, the Pennsylvania State Constitution was amended to make recommendation for a commuted sentence nearly impossible. On top of that, for decades now, no politician has wanted to vote yes on commutations for fear of professional suicide. And remember, all this happened in the 1990s, the Tough on Crime era. The result, the door slammed shut on lifers.
我的话可能只对即将到来的变化做出了很小的贡献，但它们仍然是其中的一部分。作为那次关于犯罪特别会议的结果，宾夕法尼亚州宪法被修改，使得减刑建议几乎变得不可能。更不用说，几十年来，没有政治家愿意在减刑问题上投赞成票，生怕造成职业自杀。记住，这一切都发生在90年代，那个“打击犯罪”的时代。结果是，终身囚犯的大门被狠狠关上了。
What I do remember, most of all, is that during the first year that I was the head of corrections in Pennsylvania, the first 12 months, and I remember feeling like the little Dutch boy with his finger in the dike. I mean, we just sort of creating space as quickly as we could. It was a very dramatic time.
我最记得的是，在我担任宾夕法尼亚州惩教署负责人的第一年，前12个月，我记得感觉就像那个用手指堵住大堤的荷兰小男孩。我的意思是，我们只是尽可能快地创造空间。那是一个非常戏剧性的时期。
Martin Horn was Pennsylvania's Secretary of Corrections under Tom Ridge. When the changes were put into place, it was Horn who had to deal with what those changes meant inside the prisons.
马丁·霍恩是汤姆·里奇治下的宾夕法尼亚州惩教署署长。当这些变更实施时，是霍恩必须处理这些变更在监狱内意味着什么。
Lifers in the Pennsylvania system are actually a very stabilizing force. They have an interest in the civility of life within the prison, if you will, but the lifers during those several years that I was there, were really demoralized and saw no hope of ever getting out. And a prisoner without hope is a much more difficult prisoner to manage than a prisoner who has some hope.
宾夕法尼亚州体系内的终身囚犯实际上是一股非常稳定的力量。他们对监狱内的生活文明感兴趣，可以说，但在我那里的几年里，终身囚犯们确实很颓废，看不到任何出狱的希望。而一个没有希望的囚犯比一个有希望的囚犯更难管理。
My name is Tyrone Werts. I've served close to 37 years incarcerated in the Graterford prison in Pennsylvania. My sentence was commuted in 2010 by former Governor Rendell. I've been home about three years and a couple of months.
我叫泰隆·沃茨。我在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德监狱服刑了近37年。我的刑期在2010年被前州长伦德尔减刑。我回家大概三年零几个月了。
In 1975, Tyrone Werts was involved with a robbery. Someone was killed in the process. Werts, who was waiting in the car, was given life without parole for second degree murder. Since his sentence was commuted, Werts has been honored for the work he has done related to prison reform.
1975年，泰隆·沃茨参与了一起抢劫案。过程中有人被杀。沃茨当时在车里等着，被判处终身监禁不得假释，罪名是二级谋杀。自从被减刑以来，沃茨因他在监狱改革方面所做的工作而受到嘉奖。
What role would you say McFadden played in your life personally?
你认为麦克法登在个人层面上对你的生活起了什么作用？
It was huge, huge.
它影响巨大，巨大。
In the two decades leading up to Reginald McFadden, 285 lifers had their sentences commuted. In the two decades since, there have been eight. From 285 to eight and Tyrone Werts is one of them.
在雷金纳德·麦克法登之前的二十年里，有285名终身囚犯获得了减刑。在那之后的二十年里，只有八名。从285名到八名，泰隆·沃茨就是其中之一。
When I went in, there was only about 800 lifers in the whole state serving life. Now we got 5,000. McFadden kind of slammed the door shut on the lifers in Pennsylvania.
我进去的时候，全州只有大约800名终身囚犯在服刑。现在我们有5000名。麦克法登在某种程度上为宾夕法尼亚州的终身囚犯关上了大门。
To be exact, there are currently 5,483 lifers in Pennsylvania prisons. The increase is mostly because of the overall growth in incarceration rates, not because of McFadden. But thanks to McFadden, lifers have very little hope of commutation. 75% of Pennsylvania lifers are people of color. In the 1980s, Werts and McFadden were in the same prison for a while.
确切地说，目前宾夕法尼亚州的监狱里有5483名终身囚犯。增长主要是因为整体监禁率的上升，而不是因为麦克法登。但多亏了麦克法登，终身囚犯获得减刑的希望微乎其微。75%的宾夕法尼亚州终身囚犯是有色人种。80年代，沃茨和麦克法登曾有一段时间在同一所监狱。
We inside say that there are two kinds of crime-- there are economic crimes, there are psychological crimes. McFadden had a psychological crime.
我们在内部说犯罪有两种——一种是经济犯罪，一种是心理犯罪。麦克法登犯下的是心理犯罪。
Werts said that lifers pay close attention when someone's commutation makes it past the Board and to the Governor's desk.
沃茨说，当某个人的减刑过了委员会并到了州长办公桌时，终身囚犯们会密切关注。
Because the one thing we know as lifers is that anybody gets out carry the weight of the lifer population on their back. So I mean we talk about it all the time about who we would let out, who we wouldn't let out.
因为作为终身囚犯，我们知道的一件事是，任何获释的人都会背负着终身囚犯群体的重担。所以我的意思是，我们一直都在讨论我们会放谁出去，不会放谁出去。
And what was the feeling when people heard that McFadden had made it to the Governor's desk?
当人们听到麦克法登已经到了州长办公桌前时，是什么感觉？
There was apprehension. There really was. I mean, I've heard that from a number of people. Man, you say, now I hope this guy don't make it.
那是忧虑。确实如此。我的意思是，我从很多人那里听到过。天哪，你当时会说，现在我希望这个家伙不要成功。
With McFadden's rearrest and commutations essentially shut down, Werts said a dark cloud settled over Pennsylvania prisons.
随着麦克法登再次被捕且减刑实质上被叫停，沃茨说一朵乌云笼罩了宾夕法尼亚州的监狱。
As a matter of fact, I think it's still there, because the hope has just been sucked out of a possibility of lifers getting out. That's just been sucked away. Look, the day I walked out of Graterford, there were-- they posted 200 guys in the hallway waiting to greet me as I left. And I walked down that long corridor weeping like a baby crying, because I knew as I was leaving that all these guys I was hugging was going to die in Pennsylvania prisons because they're not going to get the same opportunity that I have. And without question, I recognized that based on the changes that were made as a result of McFadden and the horrible crimes he committed, and I really want to say that I really feel bad that this had to happen to your mother, but McFadden is not representative of the broader lifer population. He was truly an anomaly.
事实上，我认为它依然存在，因为终身囚犯获释的希望已经被抽干了。那真的被抽干了。你看，我走出格雷特福德的那天，走廊里有200个人排队等着送我离开。我走在那条长长的走廊里，像个孩子一样哭泣，因为我知道当我离开时，我拥抱的这些家伙都将在宾夕法尼亚州的监狱里死去，因为他们得不到我拥有的同样的机会。毫无疑问，我意识到这是因为麦克法登和他犯下的可怕罪行所导致的后果，我真的想说，我真的很抱歉发生在你母亲身上这些事，但麦克法登并不能代表更广泛的终身囚犯群体。他确实是个反常。
Other than Reggie, I don't know a single lifer that we let go that got in trouble again. You know, they just go out and disappear.
除了雷吉，我不知道我们放走的哪一个终身囚犯又惹了麻烦。你知道，他们只是出去了然后就消失了。
John McCullough worked in Pennsylvania prisons for over 30 years. In fact, he was the Deputy Superintendent of Rock View Prison, where McFadden was before his sentence was commuted.
约翰·麦卡洛在宾夕法尼亚州的监狱工作了30多年。事实上，他是麦克法登减刑前所在的罗克维尤监狱的副监狱长。
So the whole ripple effect from McFadden has been to make us more conservative. Why take the risk at all? Just let the easy ones out. And the sad thing is, in a lot of cases, the easy ones are the junkies who are going to go right out and shoot dope and get in trouble again, whereas a lot of these old lifers will never be a problem again.
所以麦克法登带来的连锁反应就是让我们变得更加保守。为什么要冒这个险呢？就只放那些容易的出来好了。而令人难过的是，在很多情况下，容易的那些是会直接出去注射毒品并再次惹麻烦的瘾君子，而很多这些老终身囚犯永远不会再成为问题了。
I don't know what it will take to undo what's been done in Pennsylvania. In the late '90s, a lawsuit was filed on behalf of Pennsylvania lifers for their right to a fair shot at commutation. It remained in the courts for over 10 years before it was finally dismissed. Unfortunately, success stories of lifers like Tyrone Werts don't create the same fervor that crimes like Reginald McFadden's do. But after spending the past 2 and 1/2 years investigating the effects of this crime, I want to tell you this. When I testified in Harrisburg back in 1995, I spoke from a place of fear and anger. I didn't notice the political forces poised to capitalize on that. I didn't have the distance I have now to see what my testimony would be used for, what the consequences might be.
我不知道需要做些什么才能扭转在宾夕法尼亚州发生的一切。在90年代末，一场诉讼以宾夕法尼亚州终身囚犯的名义提起，要求获得公平的减刑机会。它在法庭上待了10多年才最终被驳回。不幸的是，像泰隆·沃茨这样的成功故事并不能像雷金纳德·麦克法登那样的犯罪那样引发同样的狂热。但在花了两年半时间调查这起罪行的影响后，我想告诉你这一点。1995年我在哈里斯堡作证时，我是出于恐惧和愤怒。我没有注意到准备利用这一点谋利的政治势力。我没有现在的距离感来观察我的证词会被用于何处，可能会产生什么后果。
My testimony equates all lifers with Reginald McFadden and that's not fair. Look, I don't speak for all victims. I don't even speak for my whole family, but to set the record straight, I do believe in the possibility of second chances.
我的证词将所有终身囚犯与雷金纳德·麦克法登等同起来，那是不公平的。看，我不代表所有受害者。我甚至不代表我的整个家庭，但为了澄清事实，我确实相信第二次机会的可能性。
My mom still suffers from post-traumatic stress, but she tells me that this whole project has made her feel a bit lighter.
我母亲依然患有创伤后应激障碍，但她告诉我，这整个项目让她感觉轻松了一点。
So I'm just wondering how it's been for you to do this?
所以我很好奇，做这个对你来说感觉如何？
Well, I have thought about how it shifted for me. When you started to do this piece, talking to all these people and saying, how did it affect you? Where are you now? How often do you think about it? It feels like the community is brought in again so it strengthens me and I'm not alone.
嗯，我思考过它是如何为我转变的。当你开始做这个节目，和所有人交谈并问他们，它对你有什么影响？你现在在哪儿？你多久想一次它？这感觉就像社区再次被引入，所以它加强了我，我不再是孤单一个人。
And she's actually been singing. When she's driving in the car or at home by herself, she'll sing, Not like she used to. She still cries, but she's singing.
而且她确实在唱歌了。当她在开车或独自在家时，她会唱歌，不像她过去那样。她依然会哭，但她在唱歌。
Samantha Broun. Today's story was produced by Samantha Broun and Jay Allison on Cape Cod for the Public Radio website Transom.org.
萨曼莎·布朗。今天的故事由萨曼莎·布朗和杰伊·艾利森在科德角为公共广播网站Transom.org制作。
If you want to make radio stories or podcasts, I want to say Transom.org is this non-profit with free advice on how to do that, primers on the gear that you want to get, and software that's best, as well as essays on story structure and technique by people like me and Jad Appenrod and Errol Morris and Scott Carrier and lot of others. They also give amazing workshops. They're great, again, at Transom.org.
如果你想制作广播故事或播客，我想说Transom.org是一个非营利组织，提供关于如何做到这一点的免费建议，关于你想要获取的装备的入门指导，以及最好的软件，还有像我、贾德·阿彭罗德、埃罗尔·莫里斯、斯科特·卡里尔和其他很多人写的关于故事结构和技巧的文章。他们也举办很棒的研讨会。再次重申，他们在Transom.org非常出色。
[MUSIC - "I WANT TO SING" BY FIONA KELLEHER"]
[音乐 - 菲奥娜·凯勒赫演唱的《我想唱歌》]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our production staff Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Channa Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Robyn Semien produced today's episode. Research help today from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damian Grave. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的制作人员苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明、凯伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、斯蒂芬妮·傅、钱娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克 斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。罗宾·塞米恩制作了今天的剧集。今天的研究协助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。音乐协助来自达米安·格雷夫。我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He is not into pets. When I told him I was getting a dog, he said--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他不喜欢宠物。当我告诉他我要养条狗时，他说——
I'm kind of curious what the point in the whole project is, but go for it, you know. Let's see where it goes. I don't know. Good for you. Better you than me.
我有点好奇整个项目的意义是什么，但去做吧，你知道。让我们看看它会走向何方。我不知道。为你高兴。还好是你而不是我。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。